Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Hast du schon gehört? Am Montag kommt der digitale Impfpass, dann ist die Pandemie endlich vorbei.
Ja, du musst dich aber noch impfen lassen vorher, ne?
Ah
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihundertachtundneunzig vom neunten Juni zwanzig einundzwanzig und wir rollen hart auf die Vierhundert zu,
Aber noch ist es nicht so weit, Leute. Noch ist es nicht so weit. Noch ist es nicht so weit. Ihr müsst eure Begeisterung noch ein wenig im Griff halten
so ist es. Ach ja und dann im Fass. Yes. Dann.
Es ist so. Äh die Corona-Warn-App sei denn auch bekommen.
Hat ihnen, glaube ich, sogar mit dem Update von gestern schon auch äh released genau. Also das Feature ist am Ausrollen. Also es gibt da schon eine gewisse äh Bereitschaft. Wir haben das ja hier schon ausführlich diskutiert. Kernproblem ist halt,
abgesehen davon, dass noch nicht alle geimpft sind, dass eben auch die, die jetzt ihre zweite Impfung bereits erhalten haben, dass dann erstmal nachweisen,
können sie theoretisch praktisch auch äh mit dem,
gelben Papier, Impfpass, ganz klar, aber um auf den digitalen Impfpass zu gehen. Ja, da muss das dann halt noch nachgereicht werden und da wollen dann die Apotheken einschreiten. Wir werden äh gespannt schauen,
wie sich das so entwickelt. Aber im Fass haben wir ja eigentlich später in der Sendung.
Ja, dann nehmen wir es jetzt mal ganz kurz nach vorne. Ich glaube, dass das mit dem mit dem Upgrade der Impfpässe ist ja sehr äh sehr schönes Problem. Das wird in der bei den Apotheken in sehr guter Hand sein. Ähm ich finde
äh finde einen sehr schönen Artikel gerade von
Leaks, also die sind ja wirklich in letzter Zeit äh enorm aktiv wieder. Äh deutsches äh Nonnungsgrüppchen, ähm die jetzt äh,
einen schönen Artikel geschrieben haben. Manche Käufer von gefälschten Impfpässen haben nun drei Probleme.
Weniger Geld und immer noch keinen Impfpass
Sie haben sich nämlich äh angeschaut, dass es ja auf Telegram ein sehr lebhaften, einem Schwarzmarkt für äh Impfpässe gibt.
Und haben dort auch äh sich in den entsprechenden Gruppen als Anbieter äh dargestellt und haben dann von,
zumindest einem Käufer gesagt, ja, um dir den ausstellen zu lassen, brauchen wir halt einen Scan von deiner äh Gesundheitskarte und deinem Personalausweis,
und äh irgendwie hundertfünfzig Euro, fünfzig, damit's eine Woche schneller geht. Und ja, haben dem natürlich dann keinen geschickt, aber haben hier anonymisiert dann den äh.
Den Ausweis und die äh Krankenkassenkarte äh veröffentlicht. Und auch sehr genau beschrieben, wie man,
anonyme falsch Angebote auf Telegram machen kann und Impfpassfälschungsinteressentinnen,
ziehen kann.
Ja, ist gar nicht so einfach, illegal vorzugehen, wenn man's eigentlich nicht so richtig drauf hat. Das äh fällt mir immer wieder auf, so.
Das ist wirklich also diese Seite ist sehr interessant. Also erstes schreiben die sehr schön, so dass sie,
das wirklich so einfach haben, sich enormes Aktivisten gefragt, sind diese Menschen wirklich so naiv, dass sie einhundert Euro oder mehr an ihnen völlig unbekannte Zahlen nur, weil sie die Hoffnung hegen, Impfpässe zu bekommen, ohne geimpft worden zu sein?
Ja
Sie sind so naiv. Sie sind mehrmals eine na ja, wer das alles glaubt, was die glauben, dann ist natürlich auch nicht äh überraschend, dass die das glauben,
wir reden. Na ja, sehr schön. Genau und dann haben sie äh.
Streuen sie. Und das finde ich insofern, also ist eine ganz interessante ähm Vorgehensweise, weil sie dadurch natürlich auch ähm Unsicherheit in diesem Markt sehen
ne? Und das versaut oder gefährdet natürlich auch potentiell das Geschäft der echten Betrügerinnen, die dort ähm ja,
handeln mit gefälschten Impfpässen, was wirklich eine äh eine echt äh unschöne Sache ist, ne.
Ja, insofern ist das wirklich eine echte Dienstleistung wiederum an der Gesellschaft, sowas äh da da so eine Unsicherheit rein zu äh speisen, was vielleicht die Polizei alleine gar nicht schaffen könnte
wenn die da sicherlich auch hinterher sind, da habe ich gar nicht so viel Zweifel. Also,
Ja, das wird noch spannend sein zu sehen, wie viel Erfolg äh die Leute dann am Ende wirklich haben oder ob sie dann nicht sozusagen ein doppeltes Problem haben, immer noch nicht geimpft und auch noch irgendwie,
Auch noch eine Anzeige an der Backe. Der da könnte der Sommer nicht so gut laufen.
Ja, das ist ähm.
Hat natürlich zwei Seiten. Also es kann natürlich auch sehr gut sein, dass es hier im Prinzip sich um Verzweiflungstäterinnen handelt, die sich irgendwie Sorgen, weil sie.
Impfausweis haben hier in eine äh stärkere gesellschaftliche Benachteiligung zu geraten und diese gesellschaftliche Benachteiligung ist ja abzulehnen.
Deswegen lehnen wir ja auch aus grundsätzlichen Erwägungen diese Impfpasskontrollen und Infrastrukturen ab, solange nicht
die alle Menschen ein Impfangebot hatten, ja, sie diskriminieren ja immer noch hier über fünfzig Prozent der Bevölkerung, die bisher einfach nicht
die Möglichkeit hatten. Äh und gleichzeitig, wenn die alle einmal die Möglichkeit hatten,
wird man hoffentlich potenziell nicht mehr äh eine Impfpasskontrolle,
brauchen. Insofern äh so eine,
ein allgemein Ding, was grundsätzlich abzulehnen ist und was ich habe mich ja letztens nochmal bisschen über dieses Thema unterhalten, dass.
Also sich einen Impfpass zu fälschen, ähm kann auch echt nachhaltig zu Problemen führen,
dann vielleicht, wenn man es sich anders überlegt, geimpft zu werden. Ne, ist eine Sache, dir so ein.
Gelbes Heftchen auf Telegramm zu ordern, beim dritten, vierten Versuch,
und äh damit vielleicht irgendwo rumzurennen, aber nochmal eine ganz andere Nummer, damit in der Apotheke zu stiefeln und dir einen digitalen
Pass geben zu lassen. Weil wenn du dann
irgendwie, ne? Offiziell registrierter im Fling bist, dann nochmal ein Arzt zu finden, der dir der dir quasi eine Impfung verpasst und dann irgendwie feststellt, hm, du hast ja schon,
Impf was oder was auch immer.
Ähm das heißt, du hast dann keinen Weg mehr zur richtigen Impfung, wenn sie dir dann endlich geboten wird ohne dich potenziell,
der Urkundenfälschung und des Verstoßes gegen gegen alle möglichen Infektionsschutzauflagen zu ähm beschuldigen oder zu belasten. Äh das sollte man sich also wahrscheinlich sehr gut überlegen
wie weit man da mit diesen gefälschten Dingern umgehen möchte.
Alles eine sehr unschöne Situation. Der einzige Weg daraus ist ähm impfen impfen impfen sage ich ja immer wieder.
Und hoffen, dass wir irgendwann eine Impfquote haben, äh dass wir uns die paar Spinner einfach leisten können
diese Dinger fälschen oder die die ähm sich nicht schippen lassen wollen und äh was es da nicht alles gibt.
Verstehe ich eh nicht, dass sie sich nicht chippen lassen wollen. Ah, ist doch geil, irgendwie immer online und so, also äh ist schon so ein Punkt, ne. Also ich will's mal noch etwas nuancieren.
Ich bin ja nicht grundsätzlich jetzt gegen diesen Nachweis und in dem in dem Sinne auch nicht gegen den.
Auch nicht in der konkreten Form ja jetzt technisch realisiert ist in digitaler Form. Das
Problem und das ist ja das, was du mit deiner Kritik primär meinst, ist, zu welchem Zeitpunkt ist das Ding dann äh zwingend und bindend?
Ne? Und von wem wird es äh wo, in welcher Situation getestet? Man kann ja jetzt durchaus äh das Ding einführen, die Frage ist nur, ab wann äh kann man damit eben auch wirklich sagen, so
Du hättest ja jetzt die Gelegenheit gehabt, warum hast du's nicht gemacht, jetzt müssen wir das halt irgendwie einschränken, ne? Andererseits gibt's natürlich den Druck äh aus
Tourismus und vielen anderen Branchen sicherlich hier in irgendeiner Form eine unterscheidbar
keit zu haben, ne? Veranstaltungen im Allgemeinen, die äh einfach unbedingt äh nach vorne wollen und sich ja im Prinzip damit ja auch
Kosten sparen können, ne? Also diese Differenzierung mit okay, wenn du nachweisen kannst, hast du geimpft bist und das dann vielleicht auch schnell und äh automatisierbar durchführen kannst, so, dann sparst du halt unter Umständen nochmal eine größere Teilmenge an PCR-Tests oder äh anderen Tests, die in dem Moment dann gemacht werden müssten. Das ist da eigentlich so ein bisschen die Idee dahinter.
Ähm da zwei Anmerkungen A ähm du sparst dir nicht nur potenziell diese Tests, sondern du sparst natürlich auch äh also die sind nämlich nicht,
so teuer, wenn man sie mal macht. Ich habe jetzt gerade äh eine mir mal äh in Ruhe ein PCR Labor,
zeigen lassen, den gesamten Ablauf, wir haben eine PCR gemacht, ja? Und äh,
dann auch mir bei jedem einzelnen Ding mal sagen lassen, was kostet das. Ähm das kriegst du gerade in diesen Festival-Kontexten schon zu vertretbaren Preisen hin, die jetzt, ne, also da musst du schon eine ganze Menge
ähm Impfpass ausgestattete haben, um ökonomisch sagen zu können, jetzt ist das sinnvoll. Es gibt aber einen anderen Faktor.
Und der ist ähm,
die Leute, wenn du jetzt diese Geimpften nicht mehr PCR testest, dann stehen die auch wenigstens vor den Ungeimpften nicht mehr mit in der Schlange. Und das
schlagt die Situation natürlich ein bisschen auch für die Ungeimpften, die noch getestet werden müssen
Gleichzeitig gerade das irgendwie als erstes aufs Gelände dürfen in der langen Schlange stehen, nicht in der langen Schlange stehen,
insbesondere in diesen Festivalkontexten, insbesondere in den Partykontexten, weißt du? Schlange am Berghain, irgend so eine irgendjemand läuft dran vorbei, äh hat Gästeliste.
Das sind die Geimpften, ne? Die müssen nicht mehr hier äh lange anstehen. Das sind ähm Garanten für Unmut in in solchen. Gerade in solchen Partysituationen da wäre ich also irgendwie äh vorsichtig.
Zweiter Punkt, den man noch anmerken muss, ist immer als Impfpass diskutiert.
Aber es ist natürlich auch ein ähm genauso gedacht für Schnelltest und PCR-Testnachweise. PCR-Test ist immerhin, glaube ich, was gibt der wann das zweiundsiebzig Stunden oder so.
Test vierundzwanzig, PCR zweiundsiebzig oder so, ne? Ähm um die um an dem gleichen Check quasi vorbeizukommen.
Oder halt auch genesenen Status, ne? Auch das soll ja darin abgebildet werden.
Dinge gibt's ja auch noch,
Ich halte es trotzdem insgesamt für eine für ein Spiel mit dem Feuer, was da äh gemacht wird und hoffe, dass wir als Gesellschaft das nicht,
äh beibehalten, ja? Das also da da kommen ja eine ganze Menge Sachen noch mit äh Personal,
Kontrolle am Einlass und äh ne und jetzt irgendwelche Luca, Check-Ins und was nicht alles. Also ich hoffe wirklich, dass wir äh einfach durch
diese Pandemie bald hinter uns haben und sich solche ähm,
Zugangserfassungssysteme, Zugangskontrollsysteme gar nicht erst einschleifen. Das ist, denke ich, muss man hier einfach sagen, dass das,
Wirklich gut ist, wenn so etwas hm schnell wieder weg vom Fenster ist und sich nicht irgendwie ähm nicht so nicht so einschleift, wie.
Beispielsweise ähm teilweise vielleicht auch positive Dinge wie Masken tragen.
Impfen gegen den Überwachungsstaat.
Impfen gegen den Überwachungsstaat. Das ist wirklich, macht es jetzt bitte schnell. Ich höre übrigens auch ähm aus äh vertrauten Quellen, dass äh,
die ähm Impfung mit Astracekaja wirklich jetzt wirklich sehr einfach zu bekommen ist,
ja? Ähm weil sie von allen
geschmäht wird so ungefähr. Der Hintergrund scheint, glaube ich, hm einmal die negative Berichterstattung zu sein und andererseits ähm dieser längere Impfabstand.
Der natürlich zu einem zusätzlichen Nachteil äh dieses Impfstoffes wird, weil das ja, ich glaube, zwölf Wochen sind.
Ist aber nicht mehr so. Das ist ja jetzt schon aufgehoben worden.
Ja, herzlichen Glückwunsch, aber das ist ja zu lasten der Wirksamkeit der Impfung.
Ja, richtig, also ich will jetzt hier keine UKW-äh Folge aufmachen, aber äh,
eigentlich jetzt ansteht, wäre zu sagen, Asra Sindika als Erstimpfung,
MRNA als Zweitimpfung hat nachgewiesenermaßen weder das Abstandsproblem noch äh außerdem noch eine höhere äh Wirksamkeit. Da muss sicherlich noch ein bisschen nachgeforscht werden, aber das ist so das, was sich abzeichnet.
Das sollte jetzt das sollte auch das Versprechen sein, damit am Ende dieses Astra nicht weggeworfen wird. Und dann ist es natürlich so, ne, je früher man sich erst impft, umso schneller genießt man den
durchaus nennenswerten Schutz der Erstimpfung, wenn man dann sagt, okay, dem Astra kann noch MRNA nachgegossen werden, das wird auch ordentlich anerkannt und so. Dann hat man den kürzeren Impfabstand und das erscheint mir eine
Entscheidungen und Maßgabe zu sein, die schon längst äh in der Form äh versprochen werden sollte. Es ist die Empfehlung der STIKO, aber ich habe irgendwie nicht den Eindruck, dass das ähm,
sich für die Arztpraxen logistisch auch umsetzen lässt, dass die dir nämlich heute sagen, alles klar,
wir wir vereinbaren nun mit dir Erstimpfung MRNA und zwar zu folgenden Daten und wir können sicherstellen, dass wir die Pampe dann auch haben. Da scheint es dann irgendwie doch zu viel Konkurrenz um die MRN Impfstoffe zu geben.
Ja, das wird sich halt erst im Juni dann so auflösen in Deutschland. Äh rein theoretisch ist es grundsätzlich so, wenn du Zweidimpfbedarf anmeldest, dann kriegst du das eh zugeteilt, weil da gibt's Priorisierung für.
Wie fern man das an den Erstimpfungen offiziell belegen muss, kann ich nicht sagen. Das ist es sicherlich etwas, was es jetzt in der nächsten Zeit auszukäsen gilt.
So, dann haben wir äh also jetzt haben wir äh Impfpast Deutschland, Impfpastetegramm, EU-Impfass äh soll jetzt auch oder wird jetzt kommen, ähm.
Und dazu gebe ich jetzt mal, wir haben ja jetzt ja gesagt, welche grundsätzlichen Probleme wir dabei sehen, ähm aber Patrick Breyer hat heute.
Kommentiert, was äh passieren wird, das EU-Parlament hat jetzt also dem Vorschlag der Kommission zugestimmt,
Ähm und damit wird ist die Verordnung für digitale Covid-Zertifikate auf EU-Ebene verabschiedet.
Und damit soll ja die Reisefreiheit in der EU während der Pandemie,
erreicht werden. Ähm da dort, wir hatten es schon gesagt, diese Dinger können nicht nur Impfungen, sondern auch Schnelltest, PCR und Genesung zertifizieren und,
all das kann man natürlich auch auf Papier.
Und diese digitale Erfassung dient halt der Beschleunigung dieses Prozesses, von von Einlasssituationen hauptsächlich, ja?
Auch daran die Kritik haben wir jetzt schon vorgetragen, deswegen mache ich jetzt weiter, äh was Patrick noch so schreibt, die nun datenschutzfreundlichen Covid neunzehn Zertifikate,
sollen EU-weit einheitliche QR-Codes beinhalten, damit nachweisen können, negative Tests, Impfung, Antikörperschutz nach Infektion. Die Verordnung tritt am ersten Juli in Kraft.
Und jetzt kommt schon und wird dann für ein Jahr gültig sein. Das ist schon mal gar nicht so
schlecht, dass es hier eine Sunset Closed gibt, ne, also einen Satz, wo gesagt wird, das Ding läuft aus. Das ist schon mal gar nicht so schlecht
ähm die Piraten haben sich da stark engagiert, ist ja auch klar, dass Patrick Breyer als Datenschützer das macht und er kommentiert.
Wir konnten durchsetzen, dass das Zertifikat hohen Ansprüchen an den Datenschutz genügt,
Daten auf dem Zertifikat dürfen nicht gespeichert werden, wenn es gescannt wird. Und Reisebewegungen können nicht nachverfolgt werden. Reisebewegungen können nicht nachverfolgt werden, heißt der Check ähm findet.
Offline statt und nicht online, ne? Wenn du eine eine zentrale online Instanz hättest, dann wüsste die ja, wo du jeweils diesen Check gemacht hast.
Es gibt ein Wahlrecht zwischen digitalem und Papierzertifikat. Es wird kein Sammelpass angelegt, sondern jeder Test.
Und jede Impfung wird separat bescheinigt. Leider können die Mitgliedsstaaten nach ihrer Wahl weiterhin nationale zentrale Impfregister betreiben.
Obwohl diese der Zweckentfremdung Vorschub leisten
und dem Recht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung widersprechen. Was er damit aussagt, ist, ne, wir müssen jetzt auf auf der nationalen, auf der Bundesebene schauen, dass wir,
Impfdatenbanken weiterhin verhindern, wenn sie aus anderen Gründen oder in anderen Kontexten entstehen. Und wir haben ja schon die Forderung auch von äh diesen Polizei äh Hardlinern gehabt, dass sie sagen, äh hier die äh
die fälscht nämlich hier die Impfausweise. Wir brauchen jetzt eine zentrale Impfdatenbank, damit wir einen gefälschten Impfausweis ruckizucki erkennen können.
Und das ist ja quasi so eine Parallelanforderung parallel Infrastruktur zu diesen Digitalnachweisen.
Und läuft natürlich komplett dem ganzen Ding.
Entgegen, dass man sagt, wir machen das mit Signaturen, wir machen das mit äh Zertifikaten, wir ermöglichen eine ähm eine Offline Verifikation und so weiter und so fort,
Wir möchten also der einzelne Check-In-Vorgang findet nur zwischen der verifizierenden Person und der die Impfung nachweisenden oder den den äh Immunstatus nachweisenden Personen statt. Und am Ende wissen die Ausgebenden nicht,
wie oft,
oder ob du überhaupt deinen Impfpass jemals benutzt hast oder wo. Und diejenigen, die jeweils wissen, dass du ihn irgendwo vorgezeigt hast, die dürfen ihn noch nicht mal speichern. Das sind schon äh nennenswerte Vorgaben, muss man einfach mal auch anerkennen, ne. Es gibt äh.
Offenbar so teilweise richtige kleine Schritte im universal falschen. Ähm aber wenn man jetzt trotzdem zulässt, dass ein EU-Mitgliedstaat sich eine Impfdatenbank anlegt, dann sind natürlich all diese Bemühungen auf EU-Ebene,
umsonst, weil du halt irgendein,
Rainer Wendt, in Deutschland hast, der dann hier groß rumtrommelt oder irgendwelche anderen tatsächlichen Diktatoren in anderen Ländern,
die dann eben doch wieder alles abschaffen, was hier ähm auf EU-Ebene versucht wurde, um dieses Tool irgendwie,
weniger schlimm zu machen.
Es gibt ja noch ein anderes Argument für diese Impfregister, muss man ja auch sehen, ne? Und da gilt es natürlich jetzt auch mal eine gute Lösung zu finden. Geht ja gar nicht nur jetzt um eine Schattendatenbank, um eine Impfung nachzuweisen,
sondern äh es wäre ja auch mal ganz sinnvoll, aus Staatsperspektive, da haben wir wieder diesen alten,
Disput und diesen diesen Konflikt, diesen generellen Konflikt mit, wenn ich so einen Staat.
Ordentlich führen möchte, ja und richtige Entscheidungen fällen musste, dann muss ich, brauche ich ja auch.
Grundlage dafür. Brauche ich auch eine eine Datengrundlage im zunehmendem Maße dafür, ne? Und hatten das, glaube ich, ja auch schon mal diese Diskussion, wenn wir äh Bundeskanzlerin werden.
Hätten wir einen enormen Datenbedarf. Weil wir würden ja gerne unsere Entscheidungen auf,
Grundlage, wahrer Informationen äh fällen.
So geil wie wir sind. Und wenn's halt ums Regime geht und dieses,
Dosen müssen wir eigentlich planen? Was müssen wir eigentlich für eine Aktion fahren, um Leute dazu zu bringen, zu impfen? Wie ist denn so die durch Impfung mit Masern eigentlich wirklich in Deutschland und was könnte man denn da mal unternehmen und wie viel Impfdosen für Grippe müssen wir denn bestellen? Und so weiter und so fort.
Selbstverständlich hilft ein,
Register, wenn man's denn hätte bei solchen Entscheidungen. Wenn das jetzt sozusagen aus grundlegenden Datenschutzinteressen,
problematisch ist, das ist sicherlich problematisch, ja? Heißt ja nicht unmöglich, dann muss man sich da auch ein Konzept überlegen
wie man äh diesen Bedarf irgendwas anbieten kann. Das finde ich auch eine Debatte, die meiner Auffassung nach
generell zu Datenschutzdebatten gehört, gehören muss, allein schon, weil es natürlich auch immer so dieses Standard-Gegenargument ist mit so, ja, der Datenschutz verhindert ja Punkt, Punkt, Punkt.
Im Laufe der Pandemie äh auch permanent und ich finde, da da muss dann die,
allgemeine Diskussion sich auch mal hin entwickeln und und und Konzepte anbieten.
Ja, wobei ich jetzt nicht den Eindruck habe, dass es diese Daten überhaupt nicht gibt. Ja, also dass das das alles gerade im Dunklen.
Navigiert, ne? Und man kann sich ja über einen Informations- und Datenbedarf durchaus auch Gedanken machen, ohne irgendwelche riesigen Zentralregister anzulegen.
Ja gut, ich meine, wir hatten das schon mal dieser Terminvergabe, als sie noch zentral erfolgt ist äh in Berlin zumindest, ne? Ähm mit wer kriegt denn jetzt einen Brief? Und wer wer ist denn hier irgendwie vorerkrankt? Also äh es gibt einen Bedarf und,
kann auch in Zukunft,
wieder einen etwas anders gelagerten Bedarf geben und für dieses grundsätzliche Problem von der Staat müsste mal genau Bescheid wissen, um schnell richtige Entscheidungen fällen zu können. Äh dafür muss man halt auch mal eine Lösung,
sicher erarbeiten, die eben durchaus konform ist mit den anderen Bedenken, mit das darf äh keinen,
Diskriminierungsfähige Datensammlung sein. So, was natürlich bei Daten immer das Problem ist, dass das kriegen wir nie aus der Welt.
Eine Abwägung, wie man so schön sagt. Ein Spannungsfeld.
Ja, plus, wenn du dann erstmal die Daten hast, dann kommen natürlich auch wieder alle und sagen, hör mal, der ist ja praktische Daten, die könnten wir auch noch hierfür verwenden. Äh, da so da.
Die Kiffer finden und so. Ja, es ist schwierig. Es ist schwierig halt. Ich habe nicht gesagt, es ist nicht schwierig. Nur gesagt, man muss diese Diskussion führen. Okay, let's go.
Okay, dann haben wir in der letzten äh Sendung und in der Sendung davor ausführlich über die Pläne zur Ausweitung des Staatstrojanereinsatzes.
Gesprochen. Wir haben uns als Chaos-Computer-Club dagegen positioniert, Facebook und Google haben sich dagegen positioniert. Und ähm gestern haben sich dann, hat sich dann die große Koalition,
geeinigt und zwar sowohl beim Bundespolizeigesetz. Als auch beim.
Verfassungsschutz rechts.
Und ähm ja, das ist natürlich eine schwere Enttäuschung, denn wenn man jetzt auf das also nochmal zur Erinnerung, dass Bundespolizeigesetz ist, dass in dem gesagt wird, ja, hier äh wir machen präventive,
Telekommunikationsüberwachung mit anderen Worten,
von Leuten, die noch gar keine ähm Straftaten begangen haben. Und also die werden nicht einer Straftat verdächtig. Die haben noch gar keine Bilkan. Wir dürfen trotzdem ähm mit dem Staatstrojaner äh infizieren.
Ähm und zwar Formulierung ist auch, wenn noch kein Tatverdacht begründet ist und keine
Strafprozessuale Telekommunikationsüberwachung angeordnet werden kann. Das heißt, ne, es es ist,
notwendig, dass du einer Straftat äh verdächtig wirst nach STPO, die den Einsatz äh nach STPO einhundert eines Staatstrojaners gegen dich überhaupt mandatiert
Einfach so geht's. Saskia Esken hat dazu im Februar gesagt, dass auf gar keinen Fall präventiv, also nicht unterhalb der Schwelle der
Staatstrojaner geben soll.
Dieses Versprechen hält die SPD völlig überraschend nicht ein. Es wurde noch ein bisschen darüber diskutiert, ähm.
Der auch darüber hatte ich mit Andre gesprochen, ob die jetzt ähm.
Quasi wenn die diesen Quellentheker Ü Trojaner haben, der ja zur Kommunikationsüberwachung.
Dienen soll, also der kleine Staatstrojaner, ob der quasi auch gespeicherte Nachrichten.
Aus der Vergangenheit, also vor Infektion oder vor Anordnung. Ähm ausleiten darf.
Ähm das nennen wird genannt Quellenticker Ü Plus, also quasi ab jetzt und noch ein bisschen mit Zeitreise in die Vergangenheit. Äh das wird äh von den Sachverständigen bezeichnet als offensichtlich verfassungswidrig.
Und äh das wollten sie ursprünglich in das Bundespolizeigesetz schreiben, das haben sie aber gestrichen.
Und zwar sagt dann äh Uli Grütsch äh von der SPD, uns ist wichtig, dass die Bundespolizei im Rahmen ihrer Befugnisse nicht aufgespeicherte Inhalte, sondern nur auf laufende Kommunikation zugreifen kann.
Ähm.
In der in der ähm Veränderung der SDPO vor vier Jahren, ist das aber drin, ne? Also bei der Strafprozessordnung,
geht das? Ist es drin? Das ist quasi schon geltendes Recht und äh Andre ähm,
schreibt auf Netzpolitik org Beobachter, könnten das als Eingeständnis sehen, dass die Quellenticker Ü plus, die in der Strafprozessordnung verankert ist, rechtswidrig ist. Da gibt's auch schon eine Verfassungsbeschwerde der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte.
Ähm außerdem.
Haben sie sich jetzt geeinigt ähm die auf die Verfassungsschutznovelle und damit sollen beide Gesetze.
Ähm veröffentlicht äh am Donnerstag verabschiedet werden. In der Verfassungsschutznovelle, also dem Recht für,
Geheimdienste, Staatsrainer einzusetzen, ist dann auch die äh QuellentKI Plus drin. Also,
alle, also im Rahmen der STPO, als Strafverfolgung und im Rahmen der geheimnützlichen Tätigkeit gibt es die ähm Quellenticker Ü plus, also nicht nur zukünftige, sondern auch vergangene Kommunikation,
die als offensichtlich verfassungswidrig ist, gegen dies schon eine äh Verfassungsbeschwerde gibt, nur im Bundespolizeigesetz gibt es die jetzt nicht. Also.
Du fragst dich wirklich, wer da wer da die Verhandlungen führt und ob da ob die überhaupt nachdenken, was sie da machen. Ähm ja, das ist übel.
Und das ist natürlich auch wieder frustrierend, weil wir seit über einem Jahrzehnt gegen dieses Mittel kämpfen, weil wir ähm.
Hier überhaupt nichts sehen, wie die Probleme äh die.
In irgendeiner Form überhaupt mal gewürdigt werden und es hier halt.
Inklusive der Entscheidung. Übrigens ist, dass die Provider und Plattformanbieter den den Geheimdiensten dabei helfen müssen, dein Handy zu hacken. Und das ist ein also ein ja, ein absoluter.
Skandal und eine Überschreitung von ja von allem. Völliger völliger Irrsinn. Kann ich nicht anders sagen.
Total heftig.
Verfassungsschutz, die jetzt irgendwie grade äh wieder in den Nachrichten aufgetaucht sind, weil sie mal eben in Sachsen irgendwie den,
den Vizeministerpräsidenten irgendwie Daten äh Protokolle aufgebaut haben, weil er ja sich gegen Nazis geäußert hat. Und weiß ja, das ist ja in Sachsen wirklich ein schwieriges Thema,
was ich dagegen Nazis äh wendet, so und das das geht dann einfach gegen die Mehrheit, ne? Und was gegen die Mehrheit ist, das äh landet dann im Minderheitenbericht,
Und das ist halt äh ne?
Eine Story von Philip Kig irgendwie von neunzehnhundertsechsundfünfzig, der Manori Manorita Report, falls irgendjemand von euch den Film mal neu Report aus dem Jahr zwanzig,
äh zweitausendzwei noch nicht gesehen hat, das wäre jetzt sozusagen äh der passende Filmabend zu diesem Kapitel, in diesem Podcast.
Die haben einen Wirtschaftsminister, einen SPD-Vorsitzenden überwacht. Ja, Daten gesammelt, was da geäußert hat,
und durften dann darauf angesprochen, haben sie gesagt, ja, also wir müssen zugeben, von der illegalen Datensammlung sind eigentlich alle Abgeordneten des Landtags betroffen. Das ist so,
Es ist so absoluter Wahnsinn.
Nicht nur den, nicht nur den Wirtschaftsminister. Ja, nein. Wir haben also, wir haben nicht nur den Wirtschaftsminister beobachtet, wir haben einen kompletten, äh, Landtag, äh, beobachtet.
Könnte ja sein, dass dass da dass da was Illegales passiert.
Nicht, dass sie sich da nachher Antifaschisten sammeln. Äh.
Zustände, ja?
Äh Facebook-Einträge ausgewertet, ungeheuerlich, also es ist.
Läuft nicht gut.
Martin Duligs sagte MDR Sachsen, er habe das Auskunftsersuchen, also es hatte bereits vor Monaten gestellt und eine sechsseitige Antwort des Amtes erhalten mit lauter belanglosem Zeug,
irgendwie so. Hier, da hat er gesagt, Nazis sind Scheiße auf Facebook.
Da muss man nicht lange drüber nachdenken um zu checken, dass das halt ein absoluter Wahnsinn ist, was diese was wir die da machen lassen, ne.
Sich darum kümmern müsste diese.
Institutionen wirklich zu reformieren und äh oder still zu legen oder überhaupt zu schauen, was wir da alles uns für für Verfassungsfeinde in den Verfassungsschutz geholt haben. Stattdessen sagen wir
Ey, voll geile Idee. Wir haben eine, wir haben eine Idee. Ihr könnt einfach alle hacken und äh wer euch im Weg steht, muss dabei helfen.
Also das ist halt generell einfach noch ein Problem in unserer Gesellschaft, dass wir.
Vorstellung aus dem bei den Leuten nicht rauskriegen, dass das an sich eine notwendige und tolle und wichtige Funktion ist.
Ja, der Name Verfassungsschutz ist natürlich dann an der Stelle auch klug gewählt. So ja, irgendjemand muss ja die Verfassung schützen, dass das unser aller Aufgabe ist.
Macht sich an der Stelle irgendwie nicht so richtig breit.
Und äh vor allem, wenn man sich halt das Gebaren der
des Verfassungsschutzes in den letzten Jahrzehnten, wir hatten das ja, glaube ich, auch schon äh mehrere Male und wir hatten auch dieses wunderbare äh Gespräch auf LNP äh dreihundert,
ähm äh Martina Renner, genau, genau das und ähm
ist da ja auch klar geäußert, äh hat das auch weiterhin tut und die einfach diesen Blick gewonnen hat, wie viele dass er auch gewonnen haben, was aber einfach
kaum mehrheitsfähig ist. Also diese Vorstellung man sieht das ja auch schon bei der Polizei, diese Abwehrschlachten, die da äh schnell geführt werden. So, ja, man darf ja nicht die Polizei unter Generalverdacht stellen. Das sind ja, die beschützen uns ja.
Doch.
Ja und dann na ja, was heißt Generalverdacht, also
muss ja kein Generalverdacht sein, reicht ja schon Verdacht und dafür gibt's ja genug äh Anhaltspunkte. Und das ist natürlich so, dass man das grundsätzlich verhindern muss, weil jedes einzelne übertreibt, treten äh dieser roten Linienderer ist ja einiger wichtiger gibt, ist an sich schon ein Problem. Und man sieht aber eben auch ähm zunehmenden Maße
das ja, so aus Polizeikreisen und natürlich auch aus Geheimdienstkreisen immer wieder
alles ausgenutzt wird, was irgendwie ausgenutzt werden kann, weil es eben keine richtige Kontrolle gibt.
Weil wir zwar aufm Papier eine Kontrolle haben, aber die ist halt äh geknebelt und mit den Händen auf dem Rücken gebunden unterwegs und kann dementsprechend eigentlich nicht sehr viel mehr tun
als äh die Unwilligkeit über sich selbst Auskunft zu geben im kleinen, privaten Kreise, ohne die Möglichkeit, das auch nur weiterzuleiten an der Öffentlichkeit, zur Kenntnis zu nehmen. Das ist im Wesentlichen alles, was wir an Kontrollmechanismen haben.
Das ist natürlich dann auch ein ganz normales Ding.
Kann man den dann wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal einen Vorwurf machen, weil die leben natürlich auch in so einer Bubble, in der sie die ganze Zeit erzählt bekommen, wie wichtig das ja ist, was ihr da gerade tut,
und macht doch mal. Ja, aber wir hauen euch dafür nicht auf den Finger,
Wir müssen euch ja beschützen, dass irgendwelche anderen daherkommen und können mir sogar durchaus vorstellen, dass da viele Leute gibt, die sehr wohl vorkommen überzeugt davon sind, dass sie da das Richtige tun,
aber einfach den Kontakt zur Außenwelt äh an der Stelle schon vollständig verloren haben,
Themen muss halt einfach Einhalt geboten werden. Es kann nicht sein, dass ein Verfassungsschutz äh so kontrollfrei ist, immer wieder mit diesen Pauschalargument, dass wir das nicht geheim abläuft, dass es ja dann nicht funktionieren würde. Das Gegenteil ist richtig.
Nur etwas, was wirklich auch öffentlich kontrolliert wird, kriegt die entsprechenden Korrekturmechanismen,
anheim gestellt um sich auch selber gesund und wirklich sinnvoll für 'ne Gesellschaft zu entwickeln und die Frage ob es den Verfassungsschutz an sich braucht.
Die muss auch gestellt werden dürfen. Weil da natürlich immer wieder
klar drin formuliert wird, so, guck mal, euer Dreckrekord ist einfach mal scheiße. Auf der einen Seite kriegt ihr nichts verhindert, auf der anderen Seite äh,
braucht ihr permanent eure äh Energie und ihr zieht auch noch so dermaßen viel Kohle an, also wo es wo es hier irgendwie die Kostennutzenrechnung liegt, dass auf den Tisch. Wir sehen das einfach als Gesellschaft nicht. Und ganz im Gegenteil, in dem Moment, wo es wirklich mal bedrohliche
Tendenzen gibt, kriegt ihr irgendwie euren Arsch nicht hoch. Das dauert jetzt irgendwie wat? Jetzt haben sie irgendwie gesagt, so Pegida wäre ja irgendwie problematisch und das müsste man sich mal anschauen.
Zweitausendeinundzwanzig.
Was tut ihr eigentlich da den ganzen Tag?
Das das ist doch einfach unglaubwürdig, also wirklich.
Ja, es ist äh.
Sehr schön. Wir waren beim Thema Staatstrojaner. Wir haben uns jetzt in den letzten Sendungen sehr viel damit auseinandergesetzt. Ähm.
Was das für ähm technische
wie wie was die technischen Probleme sind bei der Schwere des Eingriffs. Wir haben uns damit auseinandergesetzt. Welchen Institutionen das Recht dazu gegeben werden soll, mit wie wenig Kontrolle die gesegnet sind und
vor allem aber, dass sich diese Angriffe ja nun mal primär am Ende gegen diejenigen gerichten werden.
Die ähm ja, zum Beispiel Google und Apple vertrauen und ähm also damit äh Unternehmen, die jetzt in Zukunft verpflichtet sein sollen.
Eure Geräte im Auftrag des Staates,
zu kompromittieren. Wir haben uns auch darüber auseinandergesetzt, damit auseinandergesetzt, dass sie eigentlich viel zu viele Daten haben, die Strafverfolgungsbehörden und regelmäßig in der Flut der Metadaten.
Ja ersticken und kaum noch arbeiten können. Und jetzt gibt es aber einen viel äh.
Beachteten Fall, wo die mal ganz anders an die Sache rangegangen sind. Und ich sage von vorne herein, dass ich nicht ganz sicher bin.
Ob ich das jetzt gut oder schlecht finde, das würden wir gerne erstmal hier unter uns so ein bisschen versuchen, zu erörtern und würden uns da auch freuen, ähm äh wenn wir das im.
Ähm in den Kommentaren bei uns unter der Sendung von euch mal hören würden, wie ihr auf den Fall blickt. Es gab ja unterschiedliche.
Messenger, Apps, die sich auf die eine oder andere Weise spezifisch auf ähm.
Ja für kriminelle ähm.
Angeboten haben, also äh Phantom secure, Anchrotchat, ja? Waren eigene Geräte mit äh so einer Geheimbotti und äh einem,
ja angeblich sicheren Messenger und wurde kompromittiert,
da haben sie also quasi direkt die ganze Infrastruktur gehackt und in Folge dessen sehr viele.
Kriminelle hochgenommen und ja die Aussage getätigt, dass eigentlich äh kaum äh nicht Kriminelle äh genutzt haben. Ähm was sehr viele Fragen aufwieft. Erstens, der,
Plattform, Betreiberhaftung, ähm zweitens,
der äh ne des des Hackings von Infrastrukturen, alles sehr zweifelhafte Fälle. Darum soll's aber in diesem Fall jetzt gar nicht mehr gehen. Das haben wir damals schon behandelt. Hier geht es darum, dass sie offenbar.
Begonnen haben.
Und zwar ist das hier eine internationale Zusammenarbeit von australischen Behörden und dem FBI.
Nachdem eine eine solche Software hochgegangen ist, hat das FBI im Prinzip mit einem Informanten.
Selber so eine ähm App ja lanciert. Und die hatte Verschlüsselung.
Aber auch ähm eine geheimfunktionalität, dass sie immer alles auch noch mit einem zweiten Schlüssel verschlüsselt hat und das war der ähm.
Der Betreiber. Ja, also du hatte um sie einfach zu machen. Die Leute dachten, sie hätten eine verschlüsselte App in Wirklichkeit ähm haben konnte aber das FBI jede Nachricht mitlesen.
Ähm und äh das haben sie von zwanzig achtzehn an hochgezogen, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Und das war so ein Invite Only-Ding, ähm wodurch sie ja quasi oder die Oktober zwanzig neunzehn haben sie's hochgezogen ähm und.
Diese App, da brauchte man einen Invite. Jetzt könnte man sagen, diesen Invide haben sie wahrscheinlich durch diese Invite-Regelung konnten sie vielleicht so ein bisschen sicherstellen, dass ihnen nicht allzu viele normale nicht kriminelle Nutzer da ähm,
Neues rein generieren, ja, oder sie irgendwie,
nicht wirklich kriminelle äh überwachen, weil sie denen quasi einfach den Zugang zu dem System ähm durch so ein Bürgensystem,
verwehren konnten. Und haben also seit Oktober zwanzig neunzehn zwanzig Millionen Nachrichten.
Gesammelt und abgehört und jetzt ähm geerntet, also unendlich viele oder sehr viele Ermittlungsverfahren daraus ähm abgeleitet und ähm in Australien allein wurden.
Von tausenden Polizeibeamtinnen ungefähr fünfhundert Durchsuchungsbeschlüsse,
durchgeführt. Zweihundertvierundzwanzig Personen verhaftet und mehr als fünfhundert fünfundzwanzig.
Ja Strafanzeigen ausgestellt, einhundertvier Pistolen oder Schusswaffen beschlagnahmt und fünfundvierzig Millionen australische Dollar in Cash sowie Tonnen von Drogen. Ähm.
Beschlagnahmt. Das ist nur Australien. In der äh in Europa und den USA wurden in insgesamt sechzehn Ländern achthundert Menschen verhaftet.
Zweiunddreißig Tonnen Drogen.
Zweihundertfünfzig Schusswaffen, fünfundfünfzig Luxuskarren und mehr als hundertachtundvierzig Millionen.
Dollar in Bargeld und Kryptowährungen. Ähm.
Nicht mehr so viel wert. Grad. Ja.
Was die Kryptowährung ja die Frage ist ob sie die wirklich beschlagnahmt haben oder oder wieder nur irgendwie ein Wallet haben und sagen das ist aber jetzt, das darfst du jetzt nicht mehr benutzen.
Deswegen gehen die Preise runter. Na toll. Danke.
Also ich habe also ne, das ist ähm ach so und genau, zwanzig Millionen Nachrichten von elftausendachthundert Geräten.
Verdächtiger Krimineller. Das ist schon eine ziemlich krasse Nummer und ähm.
Ich, also ich, mir fällt's gerade echt schwer, äh ob ich das jetzt gut finden soll oder nicht.
Ja, so ein bisschen wie mit dem Impfpass, ne? So.
Die haben, die haben, na ja, die haben sowieso an und liegst, die haben halt so so Impfpässe zum Verkauf angeboten und alle so, ja, her damit. Und dann so, ja, nee, war alles nur äh Spaß, wir sacken euch jetzt hier mal ein.
Ja, die haben also sie haben, das ist eine riesige Operation, weil äh sie.
Also sie hatten einen Informanten oder einen Informanten, die.
Vorher quasi auch mit den Geräten einer anderen Anbieterin gedealt hat. Und ähm auf diese Weise haben sie es geschafft, diese App oder diese Plattform gezielt unter Kriminellen zu etablieren
und waren dann irgendwann soweit, dass sie, ja, bestimmte, besonders ähm.
Einflussreiche, kriminelle zu der Nutzung gebracht haben und die waren natürlich dann, sagen wir mal, ihre, ihre Influencer, ne? Und haben gesagt, hör mal, wenn du mit mir schreiben willst, nicht mehr Telegram, sondern jetzt äh annorm.
Und ähm.
Das lief nicht so gut.
Det lief eine Zeit lang offenbar sehr gut, ne? Und ähm äh ist.
Also ich eines, man kann, also eine Perspektive ist zu sagen, okay, war ein Hannipot, die sind drauf reingefallen. Deswegen nutzt man eine quelloffende Apps, deswegen ähm.
Ne, deswegen, ja, nutzt man so etwas nicht, ja? Hm.
Die andere Perspektive ist, dieses Unternehmen hat ja einen Eindruck erweckt
auch ähm rechtlich, die haben irgendwie so geschrieben, ja, also wenn bei uns eine Anfrage nach Daten eingeht,
dann informieren wir die Betroffenen sofort
und verzögern unsere Antwort um zwei Wochen und außerdem müssen die Behörden dafür zahlen, damit wir das irgendwie verzögern. Also sie haben im Prinzip gesagt, sobald jemand fragt, sagen wir dir Bescheid, damit du alles löschen kannst.
Und ähm.
Außerdem verlangen wir Geld von denen und verzögern das so, damit du halt Gelegenheit hast, alles zu löschen. Also so ein, so ein, ja, so ein fake Angebot an an Kriminelle, ne?
Ja
Genau und jetzt ist halt die Sache, können diese Kriminellen jetzt sagen, hier wir wurden betrogen. Könnten dir sagen.
Ja, könnten sie sagen. Und du meinst, wird dann alles als ungültig äh markiert.
Also sie sagen ähm fünfzehn ungefähr fünfzehn nutzt bei fünfzehn Nutzern haben sie sie nicht in die Inhalte geschaut, weil sie davon, weil sie keinen Anhaltspunkt hatten, dass das Kriminelle waren.
Ne, ich also unter dem gegebenen.
Umständen und wenn die Alternative halt ist, dass sie Google und Apple zwingen, ähm.
Unsere Geräte zu hacken und äh Staatstrojaner auf unsere Geräte auszurollen, scheint mir eine solche Operation dann doch, weil sie sich gezielt.
Gegen Kriminelle äh gewendet hat und ja, letztendlich war's halt eine eine App mit einer Vektor, die beworben wurde.
Äh und zwar gezielt an diese Kreise, also ich habe davon nie gehört, erscheint mir das ähm könnte man fast als Fairgame bezeichnen, ne.
Ich habe so ein bisschen gezuckt, als du vorhin äh gesagt hast, ja, selber Schuld irgendwie, für sowas benutzt man ja dann Open Source
weißt du? Also selber Schuld äh hochkriminelle äh unter wirklich kriminellen Kreisen weiß man, dass man irgendwie um
benutzen soll, die ihr irgendwie dafür gedacht sind, irgendwie die Welt einen besseren Ort zu machen. Das ist halt äh schwierig, ne. Eine Argumentation,
Ja, ich bin da auch ein bisschen gespalten, kann aber deinen Punkt,
auch verstehen, dass man das quasi wirklich so als Polizeiaktion sieht so in sich. Ne, also ist quasi die App.
Hier tatsächlich so einen ähm,
in Software gegossene polizeiliche Maßnahme ist, die man so generell als taktischen Hinterhalt bezeichnen könnte. Es ist schwierig
ne, dass das sozusagen Software hier wirklich zu einem Werkzeug wird, aber immerhin ähm wenn der Skop so sich wirklich
Also wenn das für dich sich so zugetragen hat
man sagen kann, naja, dir ist ja dann zumindest nicht die Privatsphäre von Leuten in dem Sinne verletzt worden. Das ist so für die Allgemeinheit gilt, ne? Wobei sicherlich hier auch.
Privates äh nicht ermittlungsrelevantes passiert ist,
Ne? Es sind ja auch immer Leute in in solche Kreise mit reingezogen, die jetzt sagen wir mal nicht aktiv so am, am, am, am, am Geschehen, am Betrugsgeschehen teilhaben. Schwierig.
Wie sie das eingefädelt haben, ne? Die haben zwanzig achtzehn Vincent Rames,
verhaftet, der eine der quasi der Geschäftsführer war von Phantom Secure. Und Phantom Secure hat war ein einer dieser Dienstleister für das für die organisierte Kriminalität. Und.
In diesem Zusammenhang haben sie ein Phantom secured,
der auch ein anderes Produkt namens verkauft hat. Also es gab,
zwei, wie gesagt, gibt mehrere solche äh Dinger, ne, Angrojet, Phantom, Secure, Sky Global und äh der dieser Mensch hat gesagt, ja ich entwickle jetzt übrigens neben denen, die ich verkaufe, auch noch ein eigenes.
Und hat dann gesagt, das würde er jetzt, sehr hätte das dem FBI angeboten. Jetzt frage ich mich.
Unter welchen Bedingungen dieser Mensch das angeboten hat. Ja, wenn er nämlich, wenn,
grade der CEO verhaftet wurde und du bist einer der Händler gewesen, ja? Frage ich mich halt schon, wie wie,
wie du dann mit dem äh bei welcher Gelegenheit du mit dem F wie ein hör mal Jungs, ich hätte ein Angebot, ja? Ich kann mir eher vorstellen, dass äh,
dass die dieser Mensch unter ähm in einer sehr schwierigen Situation sich befunden hat, weil er ja
vermutlich offenbar in den Fängt des FBI war und äh hier potenziell beschuldigt war eben dieses mit der organisierten Kriminalität in Halle zu treten. Man könnte also
durchaus sich nochmal nachfragen wollen, wie freiwillig diese Person jetzt dieses Angebot dem äh dem FBI gemacht hat und wie viele andere Handlungsoptionen die Person hatte, die noch besser gewesen wären in ihrem eigenen Interesse.
Sache. Also man man muss sagen, eigentlich machen die schlimmere Dinge. Also zu hacken war der schwerwiegendere Eingriff. Ähm Staatstrojaner
von Apple und Google auf deinen
Gerät installieren zu wollen, ist der die schwerere Grundrechtseinschränkungen und das und das sehr viel schlechtere Gesetz,
ja, wären eine Honeypot ähm App spezifisch für für die organisierte Kriminalität zu bauen, denen zu vermarkten und die nach ein paar Jahren alle hochgehen zu lassen, eben wahrscheinlich sogar etwas ist, was die ja dürfen.
Das ist nämlich auch noch die Frage, durften die das überhaupt? Ne, also es ist irgendwie.
Ja, also würde mich freuen, da in euren ähm hm da mal in den Kommentaren eure Meinung zuzuhören, wie ihr denn diese Operation behandelt äh äh bewertet.
Genommen. Damit winden wir uns aus dem Thema heraus.
Dann schaffen wir das in der nächsten Folge vielleicht mal genauer einzuordnen. Die Nachricht ist auch zum Zeitpunkt der Aufzeichnung noch relativ neu.
Ebenfalls relativ neu ist die Nachricht, dass äh Attila Hildmann.
Dein Freund.
Sein Telegram-Kanal auf iOS und auf Android gesperrt ist.
Was oder nicht, Subscriber.
Ich war der Subscriber, ja. Mit meinem Android-Telefon und ja.
Wieso mit dem Endorität.
Mein iPhone äh habe ich gewisse andere äh Hygienevorschriften für.
Verstehe. Wird schon stilsicher, dann auch äh durchgehend. Mhm.
Ja, ich habe, also ich habe ja natürlich äh einmal ein Privatgerät und dann mehrere
Testgeräte und Spielgeräte und Laborgeräte und auf einem meiner Android-Telefone war ich,
Telegram Hildmann Follower so hab ich 'ne Zeit lang mir angeguckt aber irgendwie auch zuletzt immer nur noch so alle paar Wochen mal reingeguckt.
Ähm das war ja dann doch schon eine ein rapide eine rapide äh sich entwickelte.
Psychose, die sich bei dem Typen davon äh anfangs ein bisschen Coronakritik bis hin zu ja zuletzt irgendwie offenem.
Antisemitismus offener äh Staats äh offener, verfassungsfeindlicher Bestrebungen und so entwickelt hat.
Ähm was hier passiert ist. Mir war das schon vorher bekannt, dass es.
Offenbar die Möglichkeit gibt für Telegramm bestimmte Kanäle für iOS, für Android,
zu sperren. Und zwar ist mir das bekannt, dass das der andere Grund, dass ich das auf Android hatte. Es gibt einige ähm ja, sagen wir mal so,
Hacking-Kanäle,
Ja, wo die äh organisierte Cyberkriminalität äh in Austausch steht oder vorgibt in Austausch zu stehen.
Und diese Kanäle lassen sich auf iOS nicht.
Darstellen. Du kannst also, wenn du unter dem gleichen Telegram-Account, du kannst dich ja,
zum Beispiel mit einem Telegram-Account bei, unter einem iOS-Gerät und einem Android-Gerät anmelden. Du musst ja nur in der Lage sein, ne, das Passwort einzugeben oder eine SMS zu empfangen. Ähm,
Und du bist quasi mit dem gleichen äh Telegram-Kanal angemeldet und dann sagt dir das iOS diesen Kanal zeigt, kann ich dir leider nicht anzeigen.
Und das Android zeigt dir den Kanal an. Und Telegram Desktop auch. Meine Vermutung ist.
Oder es eigentlich nahe die einzig naheliegende Erklärung dafür ist, dass Apple in diesem Fall ähm,
das Hacking Systems da gesagt hat, pass auf, äh ähm Hacking äh äh ist not a love in äh the in the App Store und ähm gesagt hat,
Wir schmeißen Telegramm raus, solange diese Inhalte dort zu sehen sind. Und dann hat Telegram gesagt, okay, bevor wir unsere iOS-User-Basis äh verlieren,
äh pflegen wir den Kanal als bitte unter iOS nicht mehr anzeigen. Auf Telegram siehst Telegramm äh auf ähm.
Android siehst du den aber noch und auf Telegram Desktop siehst du den auch noch. Bei ähm beim Hildmännchen,
scheint das jetzt so gelaufen zu sein, dass Google und Apple gleichzeitig die Entscheidung getroffen haben zu sagen, den werfen wir den möchten wir nicht mehr sehen. Telegram das mitgeteilt haben und Telegram den Kanal gefleckt hat als
zeigen wir nicht mehr auf Android an, zeigen wir nicht mehr unter iOS an. Aber wenn du jetzt Telegram Desktop benutzt, also die App, die unter deren eigener Kontrolle ist.
Dann kannst du den Kanal noch sehen.
So, mit anderen Worten, also sehr eindeutig, da der Typ auf Telegram selber nicht gesperrt ist, aber auf iOS und auf Android ist diese Sperre sehr eindeutig,
auf durch Apple und Google verfügt. Und es ist sogar so, dass ähm Telegramm äh durchaus äh ja schon länger
plant oder Absichten bekundet oder bereitsteht, ein quasi nicht zensiertes Telegramm, das du dir dann beispielsweise äh ne, auf einem selbstverwalteten, freien Android aus einer dubiosen Quelle installieren könntest.
Und jetzt ist wieder die Frage, ist das jetzt gut oder schlecht, dass Apple und Google letztendlich eine Macht ausüben,
auf die Anzeige von Telegram-Gruppen auf ihren Geräten. Oder
ist es, ne? Also es gibt ja auch wieder zwei Sachen, jetzt könnte man sagen, ist es ist es gut oder schlecht, dass die diese Macht ausüben. Man könnte aber natürlich auch sagen, ist es
gut oder schlecht das Telegramm den Typen nicht
äh einfach mal seine seine Nutzerbasis entzieht. Und wir sind da wieder bei dieser ganzen dei Plattforming-Geschichte, die man mit dem die wir mit dem Trump und dem YouTube und dem äh Twitter schon schon haben.
Und davor auch schon die ganzen anderen äh Rechtsschreier, die halt auf YouTube und Instagram ihre Kanäle verloren haben.
Ja, die genau, die natürlich auch noch. Also es ist irgendwie ein ein unbefriedigender äh Vorgang mit befriedigendem Ergebnis, so.
Ja
Das ist das ist in der Tat wirklich schwierig. Also diese ganze Sendung ist voll mit so schwierigen wo man.
Jetzt mal nachdenken, muss, wo es äh eigentlich schon nach einer philosophischen Diskussion schreit, äh um hier mal äh eine neue Linie auch draus ableiten zu können.
Was auch gut ist, weil ich denke, das ist auch erforderlich, dass man da so ein bisschen seine seine eigenen Linien mal überprüft.
Ja, also ne, es ist irgendwie hm.
Ich bin ja insgesamt die.
Man müsste sich, also äh es erfordert irgendwann übrigens auch mal tatsächlich eine empirische Untersuchung.
Ob man, dadurch, dass man diese Leute verbannt, sie tatsächlich schwächt oder.
Potenziell stärkt. Ne, also dieses ah auf YouTube kann's ja kein Schurbeler Video sehen, ohne dass sie sagen, verteilt mein Video schnell,
wer weiß, wann sie's wieder löschen. Der Staat klopft bald an meine Tür, weil die unangenehmen Wahrheiten, die ich ausspreche, äh äh ne, die werden hier äh von der Merkel-Diktatur zensiert,
Und viele Leute, die das dann, die das dann irgendwie glauben und ähm ich,
tendiere potenziell dazu, dass ich's schon besser finde, wenn man denen nicht den Punkt gibt, sie würden irgendwie zensiert oder es gäbe keine Meinungsfreiheit mehr. Gleichzeitig ähm wenn sie,
die Algorithmen der großen Plattform nicht mehr zur Verfügung haben und die Bühnen der großen Plattform.
Dann hat das natürlich auch zur Folge, dass sie nicht mehr so viele Leute mit ihren Spinnereien erreichen,
auch sind, also es ist schwierig. Ich glaube auf jeden Fall, dass das so jetzt nicht besonders toll ist, weil es schon ein ähm,
eine Eingriffstiefe ist die Apple da in Telegramm vornimmt und die Google da in Telegram vornimmt, die äh.
Die Frage ist, wessen Entscheidungen war das jetzt wiederum? Also ist das eine Entscheidung, die Google und Apple selbst aus eigenem Antrieb heraus äh äh gemacht haben.
Ganz sicher war das so.
Okay, dann kann man halt auch so argumentieren, ähnlich wie bei YouTube auch. Ihr habt auch eine Verantwortung für diese Gesellschaft. So und ähm.
Dass es dann äh bald, kann man ja auch sagen, ne, also warum, ich meine, wenn wenn wir jetzt eine App rausgeben würden,
wo Leute kommunizieren dürfen. Kann ja sein, wir schreiben irgendwas Geiles, wir haben eine eine coole Idee, hier irgendwie das das geile LNP Social äh äh Network, wo man sich irgendwie so charmant austauschen kann, wie schon lange nicht mehr. Dann trittst du dir so einen Vogel ein.
In irgendeiner Form diesen gewählten Kommunikationsweg,
Nutzt irgendwie andere Leute zu betrügen, aufzuhetzen oder sonst irgendwie zu beleidigen. Was tun wir dann? Sagen wir dann so, na ja, also hm.
In diesem Fall übrigens äh äh Verherrlichung des Nationalsozialismus, ne? Weil der irgendwie auch Hakenkreuze gepostet hat. Das ist ja, da ist natürlich müssen wir jetzt auch noch die Komponente darf man nicht verschweigen, dass es hier natürlich auch an den Grenzen an den an den verständlichen und guten Grenzen der Meinungsfreiheit in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
sich befindet, ne? Weil er das äh die Veröffentlichung von die Inhalte, die der da veröffentlicht hat, eben auch äh strafbewehrt sind. Also sie haben mit Sicherheit nicht nur gegen die App Store Richtlinien verstoßen, sondern auch gegen.
Gegen das Gesetz. Entsprechend wird der auch verfolgt.
Genau, aber was was würden wir denn dann machen, selbst wenn's noch nicht mal äh äh solche Gesetze tangiert?
So, da hätten wir doch sicherlich auch irgend so ein ethisches, wo wir sagen, so, ja, nee, also deswegen da fehlt's eigentlich nicht.
Natürlich gibt es Apps und Plattformen Provider, die diese diese ethischen Maßstäbe jetzt nicht haben, ne, also Pala irgendwie äh,
sicherlich überhaupt gar keine Probleme, ganz im Gegenteil, diese Netzwerke existieren ja nur darum
dafür, um so was zu machen. Da hast du dann eben auch verschiedene Ebenen, ne. Da hast du so wer ist jetzt eigentlich der Provider? Also ist es dann irgendwie Apple, die dann Pala verbieten müssen, weil Pala irgendwie nicht durch äh schreitet so
ähm weil er immer so so ein bisschen die Frage im Raum steht, was ist, wenn jetzt so ein so ein so ein großer Plattformanbieter auf einmal ethisch
komplett abschwenkt. So einen Verdacht, den man bei Facebook.
Ja auch immer so ein bisschen in der Hinterhand hält, so dieses so, was ist eigentlich hier mit diesem komischen Androiden, der diesen Laden führt? So, wo
was hat der eigentlich für ein Menschenbild, was hat der eigentlich für ein Gesellschaftsbild, was was ja, von wem ist der eigentlich gesteuert? Und äh äh in dem Moment, wo Facebook geht und und äh sagt so, ach ja, nee, hier einfach mit Trump, das war jetzt eigentlich auch ganz geil,
nicht getan haben durch ein gesellschaftlichen Druck letzten Endes, ja, vielleicht auch aus der eigenen Mitarbeiterschaft
Ähm aber es gibt ja keine Garantie dafür, dass es nicht irgendwie anders abgeht und es gibt vor allem auch keine Garantie dafür, dass nicht eben so ein Staat dann auch mal durchregiert, wie wir das in Russland und China und so weiter sehen, wo solche Plattformen überhaupt gar keine ethische äh Entscheidungsfreiheit haben, wenn da äh
Platz des himmlischen Friedens irgendwie äh abgefeiert wird in so einem Social Network, dann ist der Laden einfach schneller geschlossen und die äh Vorstände schneller ähm äh im Knast als irgendwie bis drei zählen können.
Also bei Pala haben sie's ja gemacht.
Pala ist jetzt auch wieder im App Store, ne? Muss man ja mal dazu sagen.
Ja, weil die äh nachgeliefert haben, was ihre.
Weil die, ja, weil die da irgendwie Kontrollmechanismen eingezogen haben, inwiefern die jetzt greifen und Schlimmeres verhindern, kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Aber was was hier ja der Fall ist, ist, dass irgendwie Telegram im Prinzip gesagt hat, also Telegramm hat gewissermaßen gesagt, okay, wir machen das äh mindestens.
So, wenn ihr sagt, das darf auf iOS nicht mehr erscheinen in Ordnung, dann machen wir halt eine Eiweiß, darf das nicht mehr erscheinen, Fleck.
Aber sie haben da keine ethische Regel, die da sagt, so, ach, ach wirklich, na ja, das ist ja doof. Na, dann müssen wir das mal überall sperren. Also die die
agieren nicht ethisch, gar keine Frage, die äh agieren einfach rein. Firmen
politisch und finde es irgendwie gut und sehen, aber also ich weiß nicht, ob sie's gut finden, also ob das etwas ist, was in ihrem Sinne ist oder ob sie das deshalb tun,
weil sie da möglichst viel Nutzungsfreiheit erlauben wollen, weil's ihnen am Ende nur darum geht, äh Kohle zu verdienen. Kann auch sein
ja? Kann natürlich auch sein, dass das irgendwie auch alles reptuliden sind und die böse äh
Mächte von bösen Mächten gesteuert werden und es ihnen eigentlich darum geht, irgendwie maximalen Unbild über diese Welt auszugießen, kann ich nicht einschätzen. Ähm
nur, dass sie dann eben keinen Weg sehen dann durch diese äh ethisch verbremden Unternehmen wie Google und Apple durchzukommen und dann müssen sie halt klein beigeben.
Ähm auf jeden Fall finde ich's irgendwie äh also ich man muss mal in anderer Sicht sagen, dass es schon relativ.
Krass ist, wenn Google und Apple halt ein Kommunikationskanal Anbieter zwingen einen spezifischen Kanal,
zumachen. Gleichzeitig, wenn dieser spezifische Kanal hier irgendwie Nazi-Inhalte postet, die, ja, strafrechtlich und so weiter nicht akzeptabel sind. Ähm dann,
ist es irgendwie vielleicht auch nachvollziehbar und man müsste eher sagen Telegram, was eigentlich mit euch Spinnern los,
dass ihr den immer noch überhaupt duldet und sogar, wenn Apple und Google euch sagen, passt mal auf, sagt, ach nee, da finden wir eigentlich ganz in Ordnung hier mit den Hakenkreuzen, ne? Das ist ja die andere Perspektive, die man darauf haben kann.
Ja
am Ende kommt's natürlich drauf an, wie transparent sind diese Entscheidungen, ne? Ich erinnere mich noch, wir hatten mal vor ewigen Zeiten diesen Fall, dass ihr aus CCC-Kreisen jemand für Apple TV äh die Apple TV Plattform so diese diese App,
gebaut hat, die auf Media CCC DE einfach die Videos irgendwie auf den Bildschirm bringt und Apple gesagt hatte, aber da ist ja Hacking drin, irgendwie äh da kann ja hier irgendwie unsere Geräte äh
können ja hier irgendwie aufgemacht werden, wenn man sich den Vortrag vom Kongress anschaut. Und das geht ja gar nicht, ne? Ging ja auch hin und her. Am Ende ist die App dann doch glaube ich im äh Store verblieben.
Mich richtig im Sinne.
Ich meine, wenn ich mich recht entsinne, dass da tatsächlich dann die Entwickler die Entscheidung getroffen haben, okay, hier werden.
Wir sperren den einen Kanal sozusagen.
Nee, nee, wir sperren diese Sechs von Apple bemängelten Videos.
Das Äquivalent dann zu Hiltmann ist sozusagen. Mhm. Aber ich glaube, das ist aber nicht so geblieben, oder? So.
Also wenn ich mich recht entsinne, haben sich die ähm die Entwickler dieser App äh entschieden, zu sagen, okay, wir
diese fünf Videos raus und schreiben dann anstelle dieser Videos hin diese Videos dürfen bei Apple nicht gezeigt werden, bitte geh auf äh Media CTC D E
ja? Und dann gab es natürlich auch, muss man eben sagen, gab's natürlich eine Diskussion zu sagen, okay,
Ist das jetzt äh beugt man sich hier dem zensurregime? Ja oder ist es ähm.
Ja legitim zu sagen, okay, wir machen das, Waisen auf diese Zensur transparent hin, weisen darauf hin, äh wo sie nicht stattfindet,
ja und ähm werben quasi anstelle der Zensur für äh die.
Für die Zensur freien Inhalte
ja? Und äh natürlich auch im Nacken dann, dass die Leute, die diese Apple TV App gebaut haben, da ja auch signifikant Zeit reingestellt haben und es dann eben die Entscheidung war, ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele tausend Videos auf Media CCC DE sind
tausende dort gar nicht verfügbar zu machen, weil sechs mehr oder weniger,
zufällig ausgewählte äh beanstandet werden. Und das war natürlich die schwierige Abwägung. Ich konnte, ich war in der Entscheidung nicht beteiligt, kann auch beide Perspektiven gut verstehen. Ähm.
Potenziell würde ich dazu tendieren zu sagen, na komm lieber die anderen tausend zugänglich machen.
Anderen tausend D zugänglich machen und äh den Fall,
öffentlich diskutieren, sagen Zensur, Scheiße, wollen wir nicht. Das sind die beanstandeten Videos, also Streisandeffekt nutzen und so weiter. Und sich dann in einer Situation wiederfinden, wo du eine Apple TV TV App hast,
wo tausende Videos geguckt werden können und quasi die die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jemand überhaupt an diese Zensur stößt.
Enorm gering ist. Ja, weil das ja auch irgendwelche Videos von vor ein paar Jahren waren, wo jetzt nicht unbedingt davon auszugehen ist, dass sie das ausgerechnet die jetzt geschaut werden.
Perspektiven kann ich nachvollziehen. Ähm.
Aber es ist also ja, man kann natürlich auch sagen, es ist eigentlich nett, äh dass Apple äh an der Stelle wenigstens Sachpass auf, wenn die sechs Videos nicht mit,
zugänglich sind, dann darf eure App wieder auf das Apple TV, ne? Natürlich gibt's dann auch die Grundsatzkritik zu sagen, ey, was,
Ne, ihr habt hier so eine World Garden, ihr macht da den die Inhaltswächter und so weiter. Und gerade bei den Hacking-Videos hast du das sehr viel bessere Beispiel als ähm bei jetzt irgendwelchen Hakenkreuzen.
Und das meine ich eben mit diesem unbefriedigenden Vorgang mit befriedigendem Ergebnis, weil das sie es überhaupt machen, ist zutiefst fragwürdig, weil sie es natürlich nicht wirklich auf Basis äh.
Demokratische Prinzipien und der Gerechtigkeit äh machen und es viele Inhalte gibt, die nicht gesperrt werden.
Und so weiter und so fort. Das ist irgendwie alles so ein ein riesiges äh Dilemma-Fraktal.
Lustigerweise äh haben wir das Thema CCC TV versus Apple TV äh ausgerechnet in der ähm
wo so wunderbar benannten und oft referenzierten Sendung LNP einhundertneunundfünfzig das Gesetz verstößt gegen die Geheimdienste behandelt,
die Gelegenheit gibt, noch mal auf diese Sendung hinzuweisen. Habe ich übrigens mit Hilfe unserer Transkripte gefunden eben. Fand ich jetzt mal ganz äh sportlich. Aber hätte ich wahrscheinlich auch so gefunden. Ja,
Können wir da zu unserer fortwährenden Gespaltenheit jetzt nicht beitragen, also das äh wie ihr seht schon, wir sind hier in einem Konflikt.
Gut, dann kommen wir zu den äh Jobangeboten.
Tja, gibt's wieder welche. Genau genommen ein.
Von frag den Staat, denn die suchen eine Softwareentwicklerin, Frontend-Back-End für frag den Staat.
Mitte Juli zwanzig einundzwanzig und zwar mit sechzig bis einhundert Prozent. Ähm.
Die Plattform fragt den Staat, gibt es seit fast zehn Jahren in der Zeit ist viel Code entstanden, wir haben es aber geschafft, alle Komponenten
immer auf einem relativ aktuellen Stand zu halten. Als kleine Organisation haben wir nicht die Kapazitäten, die neuesten technischen Trends zu verfolgen. Stattdessen versuchen wir auf moderne,
aber bewerte Technologien zu setzen, die uns langfristig gute Dienste leisten. Unser Text,
breit aufgestellt, aber nicht außergewöhnlich. Wir möchten möglichst langweilige Standardkomponenten verbauen und nur dort selbst Kurden, wo es den Kern,
unseres Projektes betrifft.
Äh eine Sammlung von Jango Apps, die zusammen eine Informationsfreiheitsplattform ergeben. Ähm ja, also Django.
Genau.
In der Richtung SCSS V, also gar nicht so außergewöhnlich oder gar nicht so äh.
Unmodern. Na gut, abge.
Webserver.
Postgress Elastic Search. Meine Tochter ist einiges zu tun. Ähm.
Die äh Kernkomponente hat den Namen Freude mit Oi Freedom of Information.
Freude mit Oi äh ist an von einigen vielleicht auch schwer äh leicht misszuverstehen, aber ja. Freedom of Information DE steht es offenbar.
Oh, Freude, Freude schöner Gitterfunken.
Ja, okay. Also, da könnt ihr euch ähm bewerben, wenn ihr da in diesem Team mitarbeiten möchtet in der LMP dreihundert, äh über die wir ja schon sprachen, war Arne Semsrott auch bei uns.
Zu Gast könnt ihr euch nochmal anhören Vergütung angelehnt an TVLE1.
Stufe eins, zwei, drei, abhängig von Erfahrung, achtundzwanzig Urlaubstage im Jahr, Bewerbung bitte bis zum siebenundzwanzigsten Juni,
unter Jobs at okay,
Punkt DE. Link dazu in den ich denke, das ist eine Plattform, äh wo man im äh durchaus begabten Team mit sehr netten Leuten äh coole Software schreiben kann. Würde ich, würde ich empfehlen,
den Job.
Mhm. Gut. Ich denke, das war's, oder?
Ja, damit haben wir es durch. Wir sind gespannt äh auf tatsächlich mal eure Kommentare zu dem Thema Telegram, zu dem Thema.
Anorm äh das äh wäre mal spannend hier so die die Meinung zu bilden.
Genau. Viel Spaß beim Kommentieren und wir sind dann nächste Woche wieder für euch da.
So machen wir das. Bis dahin. Ciao, ciao.